hey guys in this video i'll be breaking
down a couple of things you may have
missed
in the teaser trailer for my hero season
5.
the trailer was very brief but there
were a few interesting things that flew
by
quite quickly so i thought i might talk
about those this video will mention some
minor plot spoilers related to the
footage in question
so if you want to avoid all spoilers
then check out this video instead
as it's kind of like a spoiler-free
overview of what to expect
from season 5. but with that said the
first main thing that was easy to miss
happened during this sequence with
kaminari just charging forward
it was only on repeat viewings that i
noticed shinzo was frozen in the
background and trapped inside the air
prison
back in season 2 we saw kosei subaraba
from class 1b
and his quirk was solid air which was
used
to keep baka go away during the cavalry
battle ultimately bakugou was able to
punch through the solid air
just with his fists alone but in season
five as you can see
he's had a bit of an upgrade you know
he's improved his quirk over time
and he surrounded shinzo with solid air
from all angles
you can see the difference in the
texture between season five and season
two
uh i guess is to reflect the upgrade in
some way also
the box that shinzo is in is completely
soundproof
which means that no one can get
brainwashed whilst he's in there
this moment from the trailer is meant to
be a a replication
of this moment in the manga and i think
the anime version is better because
we see everything from a different angle
and it lets us see more of shinzo which
is
not something i would ever complain
about moving on
in one of the last shots of the trailer
we get a glimpse of tokiyami's black
fallen angel
which is a move he learned during his
internship with hawks
this enables him to fly which is not
something we've seen him do by himself
in previous seasons
and this handy diagram right here helps
to explain the move a little bit more
something which i missed on my initial
viewings
was that we do actually get to see one
of the designated teams from the joint
training arc
specifically team two which has kendo
mushroom girl
the manga guy who is perhaps the best
gag character in the series
and the guy with the black quirk as well
which we'll be seeing animated
for the first time this was the only
shot in which we see
all members of one team in in the same
shot
as a side note the guy with the black
quirk was in one of my videos
which ranks the best transformation
quirks so do check that out
if you want to know more about what his
quirk is additionally
we get a new look at bakago's winter
costume
which yeah it looks great in the anime
and for those that don't know
this costume keeps his body warm during
cold environments
uh because obviously his quirk requires
sweat to activate his explosions
deku summarized how it works in the
manga although bakago didn't really want
to hear it
but yeah the point remains with this
suit he can generate
powerful explosions even if the
environment isn't really suited to him
shinzo is perhaps the other character
with the biggest costume upgrade
as we see his famous persona chords
finally animated
in one of the last moments of the
trailer if you don't know what these do
then
firstly i'm surprised you've watched the
video this far but also i'd recommend
pausing it now if you don't want to know
the persona cores let shinzo modify his
voice to sound like a person of his
choosing
all he has to do is wait for someone to
talk and then he flicks the side of the
device
and then after that the metal plates
kind of shift around
to make shinzo's voice sound like the
voice that he just heard
the other costume changes we see in this
trailer are pretty minor
for example momo has added a cape with
an amulet around it
which i thought kind of makes her look
like a wizard this aesthetic makes
perfect sense
given the hero that she interns with
later in the manga ojiro also added a
thermal top underneath his gear as it's
winter time
but invisible girl is still wearing
nothing as usual
they really need to make her like a
special suit out of her hair like they
did for mario
because surely this can't continue like
it's just not practical to be to be nude
all the time
but yeah guys that's all i had for this
breakdown of what was a very brief
trailer
i wasn't sure if i'd be able to do one
but there was sufficient demand on the
last video
in the comment section so here we are
naturally when we get a longer trailer i
will
spend way more time doing that but um
yeah that this is all that was relevant
from
this teaser don't forget to hit that sub
button and i will see you in the next
one
until then peace out